[Music]
in some way my book is an optimistic
book because I argue about all of our
limitations and how empathy leads us
astray but in order to make that
argument we also have to have an
appreciation that we're smart enough to
realize that empathy could lead us
astray and that we're smart enough to
act those to override its pernicious
effects so it's empathy that causes need
a favor
somebody who looks like me / somebody
who does a tour or somebody for my
country or ethnicity / a stranger but
it's rationality that leads me to say
hey that's not reasonable there's no
reason to do it it's not fair it's not
impartial and so we should try to
override empathy and my outlook is very
optimistic I'm a huge fan of reasoning
rationality that we can work together
and deliberate and talk and argue and
through this come with some great
accomplishments so what I argue is that
we have the capacity for rationality in
reason this is actually fairly
controversial in my field my fellow
psychologists philosophers
neuroscientists often argue that we're
prisoners of emotions that were
fundamentally and profoundly irrational
and that reason plays very little role
in our everyday lives
which is to say well determinism of a
sort is true what we what we do how we
act how we think it's a product of
events that have started a very long
time ago plus physical law we are just
kind of we are physical creatures we are
not we can't escape from causality so
we'll just continue doing what we're
doing one of the main goals of my work
is to argue against that I think that
notions are more responsibility can be
reconciled with determinism but I think
the term min' ism is correct but none of
that challenges rationality and as an
illustration you could imagine a
computer that's entirely determined but
is also entirely rational you could
imagine another computer is entirely
determined but is capricious and
arbitrary and random
and so even in the deterministic
universe the question remains what sort
of computer early are we emotional
creatures are irrational creatures but
there is nothing not the slightest bit
of inconsistency between the claim that
we live in a determined universe and
that were rational reasoning creatures I
think it's worked with science science
is the paradigmatic case with exercise
of Reason by EF these imperfect people
has come up with extraordinary
discoveries about the origin of the
universe the origin of life the atomic
structure of material objects amazing
things and I think we could do the same
thing with morality I think people can
argue and deliberate about morality now
whenever I say this and whenever I talk
about about empathy I always get a
cynical response in a cynical response
is I think wiesen bull enough which it
today well that's not how it works in a
real world I was reminded recently that
we're supposed to live in a post fact
world right now
really in the real world people are
persuaded by whoever yells the loudest
whoever appeals to their self-interest
whoever tweaks their emotions including
empathy and I honestly don't doubt that
that's right in a short term I think
that in any case if I wanted to persuade
somebody to go to war against Syria to
give money to this cause to expel that
group from my country I would appeal to
their emotions and anybody who appeals
to their emotions be much more
successful in those who attempt to make
a rational deliberative argument but I
think in a long run over time reason and
rationality tends to win out I look at
the world we're in now and for all of
its many flaws and problems I see signs
of those moral accomplishments all over
the place what I think we care more for
people we had forgotten about that we
have a broader moral circle as Peter
Singer would say we are less prone to
kill each other as Steve Pinker has
demonstrated in his work and there's a
lot of explanation for these changes but
I think one key component has been
exercised a reason and I'm optimistic
we'll continue this in
[Music]